hey everyone my mic turned on as I was
just having a private little discussion
- um thanks everyone for coming and
morning hopefully everybody's feeling
pretty good after yesterday after last
night's stuff here and the drinks here
and then post drinks after that is you
my name is Damien Brady I work for
Microsoft as a cloud developer advocate
and so today's session is going to be
about Azure DevOps I had to rename the
title about a week ago because we
renamed the product I will talk a little
bit about that
so the azure DevOps itself by the way is
kind of Microsoft's DevOps application
with L service and we're going to we're
going to talk a little bit about that
but if you want to try it out and
there's a lot of stuff for free and most
of its actually for free so go ahead and
try it out agile calm slash DevOps is
kind of our landing page for how we do
DevOps and how you can learn to do
DevOps as a DevOps is the twitter handle
and they're pretty active as well so if
you have questions or you have comments
tweet at them they're very good at
responding there's a forum there's a
blog there's all sorts of stuff as well
and you can always tweet me demo visa
and if you want to email me also demo
visa at Microsoft comm will get to me as
well right so the first thing I want to
say is I'm a member of a Brisbane slack
Channel Brisbane developers slack
Channel and I said that I would call
them out explicitly because I've had
some very encouraging conversations with
people based based on the name
especially of Asia DevOps and in fact
Vanessa who was who did a session
earlier pointed out this tweet which is
one of the reactions that we've got as
well which is you know I'm glad that
Microsoft is finally just selling a
DevOps to people so that they don't have
to do any of this culture shift stuff
I'm gonna I wanted to get ahead of this
right that's not what we're doing
the name is just out of interest who
likes the name as your DevOps actually
let's reverse that who doesn't like the
name as your DevOps cool keep your hand
up if you have a better name
TFS I said better name yeah you have a
have a better name no okay all right so
if I yeah so look naming things as hard
and really as you're DevOps it's kind of
a nice name for the this collection of
services that we offer what I really
probably should have called this talk is
how to deploy anything to agile with
agile pipelines because that's part of
the product and that's really what I'm
talking about now so as your DevOps is
kind of the global product that we have
and then we have a number of services in
that product that help you with your
with your DevOps solution so we are not
selling you a DevOps and please don't go
back to your organization saying
Microsoft is selling a DevOps we need to
buy four of them and that'll solve all
our problems like they didn't accept my
name of you know super magic what was
the super magic silver bullet marketing
and politics obviously was the reason it
wasn't called that so as your DevOps is
just the name of the product and the
services really help you with that with
that process so at Microsoft DevOps
still means this combination of people
process and products and the focus is on
delivering value to your end-users and
so we still believe in that we have a
product that we think is really really
good and I'm gonna show you a lot of
that but we can't bring you your people
and we can't bring you your process all
right so the product can help you
absolutely but you still need that code
to change you still need people to
believe in this you know delivery of
value on a continuous basis and
monitoring what people are doing and
shifting your priorities based on what
you can see small increments and all of
that kind of stuff because this stuff is
really important right I'm not just
saying do DevOps because that's that's
what's in my job title right there's an
awesome awesome report that comes out
every year called the state of DevOps
report run by an organization called
Dora DevOps research and assessment and
that's run by Nicole for Scott and dr.
Nicole force grande primarily and also
Jean Kim and just humble who are kind of
big names in the DevOps community and
it's based on you know well over 30,000
data points of of actual real teams and
how they operate and there's four key
metrics that we talked about in DevOps
there's deployment frequency change
failure rates lead time for changes and
mean time to recover so these are kind
of therefore metrics that they want you
to focus on and these are the numbers
from this report right this is real data
and real academic research and they've
shown that teams that do this stuff well
that do DevOps well are many many many
times better at all of these four
measures so in other words they can
deploy faster they can deploy not just
you know quickly but the time between
having a change and having it in
production is much much less when they
put stuff in production it is much less
likely to fail and then if something
does fail they're much much quicker at
repairing it and all of these metrics go
in parallel right so if you're good at
one of them you're very likely to be
good at the others as well so this stuff
is important just in case you're in a
DevOps session thinking oh I don't
really believe in DevOps as well the
other really interesting thing that came
out of the 2018 version of this report
is they did some analysis of the
different organizers a sorry the
different industries that these teams
were in and they found that it
absolutely does not matter what industry
you're in this stuff is still consistent
so if you're thinking as well that's
look we can't do this deployment
frequency stuff because we need to check
everything really really carefully
because we are in healthcare or we're in
finance or something like that the data
does not show that's the case right it
doesn't matter what industry you're in
this stuff can be done and this stuff
improves not just your team's delivery
of software but it also improves your
organizational success so they measured
it based on the organizational goals
because different industries have
completely different goals so how often
did these companies meet their own goals
and if they're doing DevOps properly the
organization as a whole is meeting their
goals more often clearly I could talk
about this for an entire hour but we
have other things to look at more than
happy to have a conversation with
anybody about this report or the stuff
that's in it I couldn't talk your ear
off so as your DevOps itself is is just
a product that can help with some of
this stuff
and it consists of these five services
as your boards which is kind of planning
all your work it's it's the work item
tracking stuff that we used to have in
visual studio team services which is the
old name for this so your scrum boards
and your Kanban boards and your planning
and things like that as your pipelines
which we'll focus on is your continuous
integration continuous delivery as your
repos is get and team foundation version
control repositories where you can keep
your code test plans is planning the way
that you test your application and then
as your artifacts as well which is where
you can put your your artifacts as well
you don't have to put them there but you
can put them there they just released a
feature as well which is Universal
packages in Azure artifacts so you don't
have to put it into a zip or put it into
a NuGet package or something like that
you can just give it a bunch of files
and say this is an artifact and put it
up there and version it like this which
is kind of cool that just came out a
couple of days ago but yes we're going
to focus on as your pipelines because
I'm going to be deploying a bunch of
stuff to Azure any questions about added
DevOps or DevOps in general because I'm
gonna move through and will hit demos
very soon
no questions I've explained it perfectly
excellent so as your pipelines is the
continuous integration continuous
delivery part of Azure DevOps the really
important thing as well despite the fact
that it has Asia in the name we don't
need you to deploy to Asia you can use
Azure pipelines to deploy to AWS to your
own infrastructure at ddd sydney a few
weeks ago I used it to deploy to a
Raspberry Pi that was sitting on stage
with me like you can deploy to anywhere
it's not focused on Asia specifically so
any language any platform any cloud it's
extremely extensible so there's there's
hundreds of extensions that add new
tasks for your build or your release
pipeline we have native support for a
lot of containerization stuff and we'll
see some of that too kubernetes whether
you're managing that yourself or its
managed service with Azure or with with
AWS or somebody else and then the big
thing the big announcement that came out
when we released Asia devops was this
support for open
source so you basically if you have an
open-source project or any public
project on github or bitbucket or
somewhere like that
you get free builds and releases for
good it's just free right so you can use
this stuff without paying anything if
it's a public project I'll drill into
that a little bit more Microsoft as you
probably know has a bit of a mixed
history with open source we've come from
days of a former CEO saying Linux is a
cancer and we're not trying to rewrite
any of that history what our current CEO
is saying is look try to judge us based
on what we're doing now and what we're
doing in the future and as an example of
that this is another completely
tangential thing which came out the
other day we're actually contributing in
into a hack Toba fest which is this
basically this global non-microsoft
thing about submitting pull requests to
open source repositories so Microsoft's
joining it and we have eight and a half
thousand a few more than eight and a
half thousand open source repos on
github and if you submit a pull request
to them in October we'll send you a
t-shirt which is kind of cool and I
don't want to think of the logistics of
that either especially one of the guys
who's managing this who did this tweet
you should have here you should have
heard him talk about how gdpr means that
they people can't actually give us their
addresses so we can send them t-shirts
don't know how they got around that but
we're doing this as well
oh that link by the way really hard to
see so there's another one demo dot ms /
ms - Oktoberfest if you want to take
part there's the blog post showing how
to do it basically submit a PR to any of
the open source libraries by the way
that includes Docs Microsoft comm so hot
tip if you see a typo
you can you can spend four seconds and
get a free t-shirt which is why I don't
want to think about the logistics so
we're actually like getting behind this
open source stuff so the azure
pipeline's offer for open source is
unlimited build minutes and this is
whether you're using your own
infrastructure so your own agents on
your own infrastructure or whether
you're using the hosted agents so we
host build agents for Windows Linux and
Mac so you can actually build iOS apps
on hosted agents without installing any
of your own stuff or needing a MacBook
and up two free attend free parallel
jobs so you can run ten builds at a time
or five builds and five releases you can
do all that sort of stuff as well so I
kind of thought we should start at this
integration with github because we're
talking about open source and we're
talking about building this stuff with
Azure pipelines for open source stuff so
one of the other announcements that came
out at the same time was integration
with github we have a marketplace github
marketplace app are they called apps I
don't know everything's called apps
github marketplace offering which makes
this pipeline really really nice to use
as your pipelines and actually use this
offer for open source stuff so let's
have a look oh yeah I was testing the
Wi-Fi it's pretty good way better than
home so here is my github repo is that
big enough for everybody
yep great so this is basically just a
dotnet hello world it's a dotnet new
razor application and let's just pull
this open yeah cool that's the one so
I'm gonna open that in vs code just so
you can see it cool so yeah just a
straight asp.net core application the
code is in github and it's a public
project which means that I can make use
of this pipeline stuff all right so to
get started you can go to marketplace
and then scroll down a bit we're not
right at the top which is fine
continuous integration and there is an
extension here as your pipelines which
moves every time I go to this page but
it's up here now so look for Azure
pipelines and the rocket click on that
I've already granted access to this I
think all right so I can configure that
or I can set up a free trial what I'm
gonna do I'm actually gonna choose this
free one by the way you can add parallel
jobs if you want to if that's not good
enough for you you can do that directly
through a github and this is going to
tell me I already have it nope cool
I successfully removed it and it tells
you what you get so Linux Mac OS and
Windows 10 for free parallel jobs and so
on by the way if you have a private
repository so if you don't have an open
source project
you still get 1800 minutes of hosted
sorry hosted builds per month and one
parallel build agent right so we're not
leaving private projects behind we're
just making it much better for public
projects there used to be two hundred
and forty minutes as well so they've
they've massively increased that all
right so let's do that and it's gonna
say that I do have it installed let's
just and I don't have it installed cool
that's good there we go so I can either
choose to give it access to all my repos
which I don't want I'm only gonna give
it access to this dotnet DevOps one and
it will have access to a bunch of stuff
so let's just put that in it's reminding
me to log in so I'm logging into github
first and logging into my Microsoft
account for visual studio team services
to connect them all up
sorry not visual studio team services
that's one all right I have a bunch of
these as a DevOps projects so I'm gonna
use my MS demos let me zoom in so you
can see but if I didn't have an existing
as a DevOps
organization I can create a brand new
one and this is free as well I'm not
paying for any of this and I can either
select a new prospective project or
create new
I'm gonna create a new one I'm going to
call it dotnet DevOps I'm gonna say
continue so that's going to go and set
up the connection between github and my
as a DevOps instance and it's going to
set up it's going to give me an the
ability to set up a pipeline so get
started with this stuff so it's creating
the project at the moment and in a
second it'll bump me into the pipeline's
feature as well one thing that you'll
notice as well when this completes is
that visual studio team services used to
have all of those features installed so
you automatically had your work items
and you had your repositories whether
you use them or not and you had your
builds and your releases and stuff like
that we've changed that a lot with this
so the only option I have now is
pipelines that's the only thing that's
currently turned on I can turn on the
other ones that's fine but if I'm only
using pipelines then I don't really need
to see work items or I don't really need
to see you know the test plans and
things like that so that's the only
thing that's turned on at the moment I
it between to this new pipeline so let's
just create a new one this is where my
code is it's already connected to github
so my repo is donate DevOps it's not
always great as selecting the right
template to use it's just saying I don't
quite know what you've got there here's
a starter pipeline that's the
recommended one I'm doing an asp.net
core one so I'm gonna choose that as my
template and it's going to create a
Yammer file so the difference between
this experience and the previous one or
the the old one and visual studio team
services is it was much more visual that
was the that was the vision that you got
was basically a list of tasks and you
can set all of the all of the properties
and so on in the UI you can still do
that and we'll do that a little bit
later but we've moved a lot more towards
easy amal build definitions and the
reason is that that means your your
configuration your way of building your
application sits alongside your code so
before if you made a change to your
application and you had to change your
build
then you had to choose which one of them
to break first you either change your
code and the build breaks or you change
your build and it doesn't compile the
current code so if you're doing stuff in
a branch for example it's really
difficult to connect a line those two
things so having your build definition
right so right alongside your code means
that you can make a change to your code
in a branch and make a change to the
build definition that matches what
you've done to your code it means it's
versioned it means that you can see
exactly what's happened with your build
definition it means you can go back in
time and say I want to build the code at
this particular point in time and it
also has the build definition at that
particular point in time so this is
really powerful so this is the template
that it's given me
yeah Mel and the the stuff that you put
in there is not as straightforward as
dragging and dropping you know kind of
tasks so there's some pretty good docs
around how to do it so let's actually go
and use those docs to do what I what I
want to do at the moment there's one
step which is a dotnet build right so I
want to add a little bit to that I want
to do a donut restore first I want to do
a dotnet build I want to publish it and
put it in a zip and I want to push it
back up to visual studio sorry this to
to add a DevOps to so I can use it to
release to agile later so let's do this
the way that I would expect other people
to do it click on that link to go to the
docs and let's just run through and say
this is how we would expect you to do a
dotnet core application so our build
environment we've got our pool that's
already set if we need to use a
particular dotnet core version we can
specify that as well with this task we
can restore the dependencies just by
doing a dotnet restore so I'm going to
take that one let's do that and let's do
a dotnet restore first great let's go to
what's next we're building that's great
don't it build running tests I don't
have any tests demo code doesn't have
tests de mocha Joe doesn't have tests
nice um alright so publish build
artifacts so I want to publish the
artifacts that I built as well there was
another one as well sorry dotnet publish
Oh that's further down so you can
basically go through this step these
steps deploy the web app from the build
pipeline if you want
I wouldn't recommend doing that you can
build a container there's there's
explanations of how to do all that sort
of stuff so you can go through and work
all this stuff out the actual
deployments here you can see all of the
different things you can do and then if
you go to reference here are the tasks
and there's all of these build tasks
that will show you exactly how to how to
do that work so the actual build tasks
there's also utility ones test ones and
they will show you the yam all that you
need to put in there to actually
construct your build definition I'm
going to take a shortcut because I'm
lazy and I'm going to do that so that's
just a bunch of yam or that I've got
pre-prepared so we're doing our dotnet
restore we're doing a dotnet build we
are doing a dotnet published but rather
than just using a script step we're
using one of the built-in tasks which is
the donut core CLI so don't net publish
publish Web projects here's some
arguments and then zip it after the
publish so you can use tasks that we
have or you can use you know just script
files as well or scripts as well and
then I'm going to publish my artifact so
I'm going to publish my my build up so I
can use it later so that's my build
definition and I'm gonna save that and
run it now I could commit this directly
to master and actually I think I will
because demo demo code and so that's
actually just going to create an azure
pipeline so yeah more in my repository
so if we jump back to github I don't
know DevOps we should be able to see
there is now an azure pipelines yeah
more dare alongside my code so that's
all it's done it's just added that Yama
file but as a result as your dev ops I
was nearly three as your DevOps has now
picked up the fact that I have a build
definition in there and it
just doing a continuous integration
build because I have that definition
so it's grab the agent it's getting the
sources it's gonna do a dotnet restored
Arnett build release don't it publish
and so on cool while that's running any
questions about what I've done so far
I'm gonna do more stuff awesome
everybody looks like good yes question
yeah so the question was how do you
support things like publishing to
octopus because that used to be with VST
s you absolutely can so the tasks that I
had there for dotnet don't net publish I
think which was a build task it had a
name which was dotnet CLI something
other like that that name can also be
used for any of the extensions so any of
the extensions that you installed that
added new tasks they also have an ID
they basically just have a name that you
can use so I'll show you in a minute how
to get one of those actually why don't I
just show you now nothing like going
off-script so if we did for example
here's an asp.net full I think I have a
pipeline set up even if I don't let's
just do one yeah there we go let's edit
that pipeline so this one I don't think
is using the Yama definition this is
using the UI so you can still do this
you can still use the UI so if I wanted
to grab let's actually add the octopus
one create an octopus release for
example just to choose that one I can
once I set this up this is going to be
awkward let's do a new one I'm pretty
sure I wrote this so I can just like I
think I know you can just
and then the API key is that I
remembered it project name you can just
type that all right we're good so let's
not queue that but let's save that and
then up the top of this task you can
view the yeah more for that task and so
you can use that same yeah Mille in a
yeah more build definition and that's
from an extension that I got from the
marketplace as well so we're not we're
not restricting the tasks that you have
done before if you are using octopus
fantastic you can keep using octopus the
name of this task is a little bit longer
than the others
octopus deployed octopus yeah yeah so
that's the full name of the task it has
to be fully qualified if it's not one of
ours but it's exactly the same there's a
yeah mall definition for any of those
extended tasks as well that's a good
question thanks I own I could answer it
alright so this build has now completed
and although this completed I can have a
look at the artifacts as well and I have
a drop folder and I can use that inside
as our DevOps later on and it's just got
the zip which is my application so
that's cool I have that artifact in
there but I haven't deployed it anywhere
yet I've just got just got this build in
the builder succeeded one other thing
which is quite cool is if you use github
and you use pull request methods and
things like that this will actually
integrate really nicely with the checks
so if I made a change to this and made
it hello Sydney
will save not bugs there we go let's
commit that and push
all right sure I guess other people have
done changes how it's actually me adding
the the yeah Mille so let's try that
again just incidentally as well when we
do this I just did that against master
so that was dumb
alright let's do it this way I get can
anybody help we through it get come in
so I don't have to hit I'm stuck over
Flay I want to do a new branch be and
then it'll just do a new one if I do it
what am i doing
title what I'm doing DevOps yep I'm
doing a DevOps there's making another
change though Sydney properly this time
make that change now we are hopefully in
that
and let's push no upstream yeah publish
it too I need to do that and I that's
this is how I work by the way I just do
get push let it complain and I just copy
that does everybody else do the same
thing I feel like that's not uncommon
alright I think I'll have to a branch
back in github I should be able to say
that when once that's pushed there's a
new pull request so what's cool is that
I have this new pull requests when I
create it it'll go through the normal
standard checks and you can see here
that there is a check for that build
definition that I've defined so if we go
back to Azure DevOps and so that'll
actually kick off and start doing a
build if we go back to Azure DevOps
which is here we should be able to see
in our builds it's doing this new one
which is a pull request build right so
if that build fails it's not going to
let me merge that back into master which
is really really handy for open source
projects right if we actually have a
look at that that build definition again
we can see that the triggers there's two
of them set up so you can change this if
you don't want it to work like this but
there's the continuous integration and
then there's a pull request validation
trigger as well so just out of the box
without me doing anything it does this
pull request validation and then in
github once it's completed that build
it'll say yes it's ok you can merge now
cool that make sense I did that the hard
way but by forgetting to do branches and
things but that that's how it works just
out of the box I haven't really done a
lot of work here so we have this build
but we need to we need to deploy it
right we need to push it to Azure
so let's actually just go up to Asha
first and we'll create a new website to
deploy it to as the kind of first thing
we want to do so web app let's create a
new one called dotnet DevOps let's use
let's do it on Linux because it's it's a
taste peanut core I'm going to create a
new hosting plan by the way if you need
to know what a hosting plan is
it's basically just how much am I going
to pay for this thing marketing probably
wouldn't like me saying that than anyway
so this is going to cost me about 93
bucks a month if I wanted to use it and
I'm just using a paid one too so it's a
little bit faster so let's this one demo
so I'm using that and I can also choose
the runtime stack that I'm using in
Azure by the way there's a lot of node
there's a few PHP s there's a version of
Python Ruby Java but I'm using dotnet
core 2.1 sorry that wasn't there to be a
question there is java as well so let's
create that so that's going to create an
empty web app for me which is Linux and
it's expecting that I'm gonna run donate
core on the thing so I have this place
to deploy it to there's a few different
ways I could deploy it I could right
click publish but everybody knows you
don't do that right you want to set up a
pipeline and we have a pipeline here for
building but then I want to use the
release feature inside Azure DevOps
rather than add your pipelines as well
rather than just the just doing it in
the build I don't want to deploy in my
build definition so let's go to the
releases section I actually just to let
you know I have to because I have a
preview one turned on as well so let's
go to the preview one because it's much
prettier and there's no release pipeline
found so because I'm zoomed in oh
there's a bug I can create a new
pipeline like that or I can go to my
build and let's choose the CI build and
straight from there I can say I want to
release this so that'll that'll set some
of this up for me it'll set up their
continuous deployment trigger and it'll
say this is the artifacts that that
you're going to get so all of that
stuff's done for me and then it gives me
the option of a bunch of different
templates for releasing as well so as
your app service deployment is what I'm
doing we're going to call this deploy to
production because that's what you do
and then there's a few settings that I
need to set up to deploy to Azure I need
to give it an azure describ as a
subscription as that
created already has let's pin it great
so we've got this dotnet DevOps one my
ad your subscription I've got a few of
them here I have this one which is this
is me being cloud privileged which means
I don't need to pay for any of it
that's on uncle Satya so I can either
authorize that and will give me access
to everything in that subscription but I
probably don't want to do that I want to
click the drop-down Advanced Options and
restrict it to just the resource group
that I'm using I don't want it to have
access to everything if somebody changes
that release definition so it will
deploy to somewhere else or delete
resource groups or something like that I
definitely don't want that
so did I I put that in a new one didn't
I don't know DevOps
that's the one I just created so zoom
out and say ok so this is going to set
up a service principle between Asia and
Azure DevOps which only has access to
that resource group if you want more
control there is a full version of that
service connection dialog or you can go
into Azure and set all this stuff up
really specifically which is probably
what you should do but again demo code
so I'm just gonna start using that now
thank you for that that was Damien
McLennan who said that as well by the
way so he also has demo code I believe
yes yes alright so that's one thing
we've got our subscription there it's a
web app and then the app service name it
might not find this because it's brand
new No so let's just call it dotnet did
wops
so that's the app service that I'm
deploying to and so those the only
settings I need to I need to set that'll
go away in a sec so I'm it's by default
selected I'm gonna build this on a
visual studio or Windows machine with
Visual Studio 2017 I'm not going to do
that I'm gonna use the hosted Linux
actually I'm going to use hosted a boon
to 1604 so these are the hosted builds
these are the ones that you have all of
your
three minutes on without installing any
of your infrastructure but you can also
set up your own infrastructure as well
if you wanted to use something else I'm
going to just choose Ubuntu so it's
going to do this this work on a boon to
agent that we host for you now they're
still complaining about this so let's
just choose these again it might save no
it's not going to save some of this is
new by the way so we get some
interesting behavior oops
oh that's good all right relayed this
didn't happen when I ran through the
demo before stage as well let's do this
again it's create and you release from
here I'm gonna do this much quicker
release as an app service deployment
Road task we'd already set up that
subscription that's great it's a web app
don't net DevOps thank you alright
the JavaScript works at that time and
then we're gonna choose how I've been to
1604 all right it's much faster when I'm
not talking isn't it so let's save that
and now we have a pipeline which has a
build definition defined in Yammer and
it also has a release definition in
Azure DevOps as well so the combination
of this means that when there's a new
build a new change to my code in master
it'll build it and it will deploy it out
to Azure so we can just set up a release
here but why don't we just merge that
pull request because you can see that
conflict has or the the checks of all
past that build has succeeded we can
even drill into the details and if we do
that we go into the the checks pages and
we can drill into that into as our
pipelines and that build and so on so we
can see all of the stuff the same way
you would in any other github project
again all right so let's merge that pull
request and we should see as well
because we now back into master will do
another build and a release here so in
builds there's a CI build up and running
for github so that'll complete we'll get
our artifact and then we'll push that
out of factory so that'll take a minute
or two and I ran through a few different
things any questions about what I've
shown you this this kind of flow from
github for the open source libraries
yeah
so the question was is there a way to
tag that it's a PR build rather than a
master build that is a fantastic
question and I don't know the answer off
the top of my head so I don't know the
answer I will come back to that one yeah
hit me up later there's somebody
somebody else will be like yeah just do
this but I don't know what that this is
yep you can I mean I was I was looking
as well you can do branch filters as
well I think you might need to put a
task in there to have a look at that
filter and then target bathe or have a
look at where it came from and then
target appropriately but that means that
that task exists in the build definition
for everything it's just it's going to
be dependent on where it comes from so
yeah there would be a way to do that but
I just don't know if the top of my head
any other questions
once that I can answer would be great
nope okay
so while that's going ahead I want to do
one more thing
I'm just deploying to this web app that
I created by clicking on stuff in the
azure portal which is not great DevOps
practice okay it should be part of my
definition of my application like
building that infrastructure I shouldn't
have I shouldn't have to call the
operations team and say can you just
provision a new web app because I need a
place to deploy it to all right that's
not a great way of operating so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to add that
definition of the infrastructure I need
to deploy to to my to my release
definition to say this is the
infrastructure you need to release to
and we're going to deploy that and we're
getting a little bit more into the
deploying anything to Azure as we do
this as well just to show you that this
is working that build is completed so we
are now kicking off a deployment to
production and if you haven't seen this
UI if you've been using visual studio
team services the UI is really nice
so we can look at the logs as well but
we can also see this in progress stuff
which is very pretty
yeah so you can see how it's going you
can also if it fails you can redeploy
from here and things like that much
nicer than it was all right so we've got
our dotnet DevOps web app but I created
this manually by going through and
clicking on stuff which is not great we
don't want to do that so let's go to
this dotnet DevOps web app let's go to
the resource group that we created and
let's generate a template to define this
resource group so all of the different
things that I'm going to deploy
alongside it if we go to that resource
group and by the way in Asia a resource
group is pretty much just a collection
of stuff that's that's grouped together
and build together and you can you can
do stuff together right it's a good way
of grouping all of the different things
that run with an application you can see
there's two things here there's that
service plan that I created and then
there's the dotnet and DevOps web
application that's there so I want to
create what's called an arm template
which is an agile Resource Management
template which defines this and I want
to include that in my release definition
to say if this doesn't exist create it
if it does exist and it's different to
what I've told you you need to create
update it there's a few different things
you can do there this is the way that I
generally get these arm templates out
because it's a little bit of weird Jason
it's hard to just handwrite I go into
the resource group itself and I go to
deployments because it lists all of the
things that you deployed as a resource
group whether you did it through code or
not I can see one website that I created
and if I go to a template I can see the
Jason that was created and I can just
copy and paste that there's one more
thing that I need to do to get this
running first and so I'm just going to
duck back to here
it's an asp.net web application but
out-of-the-box the web app doesn't know
what to run so in application settings
I'm just going to quickly add a setting
here
which is the startup file so it's
basically saying run net and don't net
I'm DevOps TLO so it knows how to run
the thing that's not going to be my
template because it wasn't in that
deployment but if we go back to that
template it's just another setting that
you can add in there so part of that
Jason alright so let's do this let's
grab the deployment let's go back again
let's see that template so there's a
template there and then there's a bunch
of parameters as well so usually you'll
grab both of these and you'll put them
in with your code I've done that ahead
of time thankfully so I don't know why I
cleared that that's weird
let's just do a pool so in my repo I've
actually got an arm template so this has
got the template itself the only thing
I've changed is I've added a startup
parameter and then that belongs here as
app command-line so I'm just using that
parameter so I can change it later on if
I wanted to if I wanted to run something
else and then in my parameters file I'm
just setting that to dotnet got a net
DevOps DLL
so the definition says here's my web app
and here's how you actually run that so
anything in Azure that you can change
with that UI you can also change in this
template alright so I have that template
I need to do one more thing to my build
definition as well let's go to my yeah
mall there's my other pipelines yeah
mall I need to add one more task here so
I'm publishing my web application but
that doesn't include my template that
I've added so I also put that in a
how good that's just that cool so this
is the same one build the publish
artifacts but I'm saying get it from the
arm template folder and put it in as
another artifact called arm template so
this means that I've got two artifacts
from my build now I've got my built
application and I have my arm templates
and that those will both be available to
my to my release definition so let's
change this Aled yeah mo grab that
commit it directly to master push and
then over here in my release definition
once that builds it should actually it's
going to build it's going to create
those two artifacts so we can see
there's that CI build for github is
completed that was the one that I did
before if we wait here for a second it
should hopefully kick off a new one
there we go it's my new build so that
new one with my yeah mall template is in
there so when that completes I will have
two artifacts that I can use in my
release um let's just what let's just
have a look at what this one did while
we're waiting for that build to complete
it's gone to prod and if we go to donate
DevOps
and go to that URL should hopefully see
that up and running so this is deployed
to this known this known web app so the
changes that I've made now we're just
waiting for that build to complete and
then it will kick off a another release
which I'll probably cancel actually
let's just edit the pipeline and make
that not do continuous deployment and I
need to change the task for that build
definition as well so it can use that
that other task for the build definition
sorry the release definition I missed
out that sentence again we're going to
change the tasks for that release
definition to grab the arm template and
define and actually deploy that and then
deploy the application on top of that
the web application on top of that so we
need another task here actually let's do
this is another
Faye's so the agent job is going to be
deploy infra this one is going to be
deploy app they're in the wrong order so
let's just move that and then we need to
add a resource group template and so
this is going to ask for an Azure
subscription we're using the same
resource group so that that that
subscription is still fine the service
plan is still fine the resource group
we're using ears dotnet DevOps it's
deploying to Australia South East I
think I said and then our template needs
to be this linked artifact so at the
moment we only have that one artifact
I believe we only have that job folder
so when that other build completes with
the change to add the arm template and
the build that should define that arm
template we'll have another option
available to us so I can't do that now
that build is completed let's look at
the artifacts and we can see there's two
of them now there's the build and then
there's the arm template so if I go back
and make that change again to the
release definition apologize for
skipping around a little bit here it's
difficult to do a couple of things in
parallel so let's do that again let's
add a new agents profit infra but now
because there's a build that's actually
being created it knows about this other
it knows about this other artifacts that
I've got same thing resource group is
don't know DevOps location is Australia
east-southeast I think and then
templates we should be able to see
there's another one here now there's an
arm template so I'm saying this is the
template that I want you to use to
define my resource group and then here's
the template parameters so again the
parameters file that I that I added
oops parameters
and then in this definition I can
override stuff as well
so I can say well I don't want it to be
called dotnet DevOps because I've
already got that I want to deploy to a
different location this can be set with
variables too so you can say I want a
different template or a different web
application for my different
environments so rather than it being
demoed net DevOps I could use a variable
in there but at the moment I'm just
going to do - - it actually writes out
all of those so I can kill the rest of
them and then save that the other change
I need to make though is to tell this to
actually deploy the web application -
dotnet DevOps - so when I save that and
create a release that'll create the
infrastructure for me and then it will
deploy the web application to that
infrastructure so as well as the
application itself we're doing
infrastructure as code and we're
defining where it needs to be deployed
to now that template that I've got is
just for that website but you can do
this for anything so if I added a Cosmos
DB or nearly everything if I added a new
Cosmos DB and just chose some names by
the way I just mash like when I was
practicing this I mashed the keyboard
here and it said no somebody's already
used that one this is amazing
so I can also get automation options for
this I can get my template and my
parameters for my Cosmos DB or my sequel
database or my network like virtual
network I can do all of this stuff and
define that as part of my definition so
you can really deploy anything that you
can deploy to Asia can be done and
defined with this these arm templates
and then of course because we're just
using script steps or we can just use
script steps we can really do anything
we want on these agents so again we can
deploy anything we want to any of these
clouds if we go back to our dotnet
DevOps resource group
we should see if we refresh this after
it's done some work that there'll be
another web application that we've got
oh what'd I do wrong these lists this is
a good example of it giving you complete
access to these logs deployment failed
starting deployment there were errors in
that cool cannot find server farm with
s1 demo did I call it something else oh
no I didn't but I also deleted it so you
got the idea you can deploy the
infrastructure with it and you can
deploy the application on top cool I
need to move on and you can any
questions about what I've shown you no
good cool one thing I will mention as
well is you can you can create this
entire pipeline sample code and all
sorts of stuff from another part of Asia
called Azure devops projects and it will
give you sample source code and give you
a number of options of where to deploy
it it'll build docker containers it'll
do all sorts of stuff I had an example
here which was go for example that's
running in a docker container that gets
created as part of your build uploaded
to as a container registry and then
deployed into a kubernetes cluster for
example you can set this up and see how
that looks in Azure pipelines which is
really really handy for learning how
this stuff fits together and if you
don't want to use those parts to those
areas to start you can start inside
Visual Studio you can start inside the
azure portal you can start inside Azure
DevOps itself or you can start inside
github which we just walk through as
well so there's a number of entry points
for this as a pipeline stuff as well so
just to summarize as well as a DevOps
itself is this collection of services
that are available to you as your
pipelines is kind of their draw card as
far as I can see it it's the pipeline
for any of your projects deploying to
any location it's easy to setup and it's
completely free for open source projects
as well so I would encourage you to give
that a go go
have a look the pricing is pretty good
even if it's a private repository and
you're doing your own private work six
bucks a month is not bad and then the
rest of it is completely free to a
certain extent for private stuff and
completely free for public I will be
around for questions afterwards but
apart from that thank you very much
[Applause]